Netflix is warning fans about the risks
of a new social media challenge inspired
by its hit movie bird box the r-rated
film star Sandra Bullock who plays a
blindfolded mother fleeing from a
sinister force Jamie yuccas shows us how
some people are mimicking the scenes
often with painful results Jamie good
morning good morning just last week
Netflix bragged Bird box was one of its
most popular films ever but now that
fans are finding new ways to parody this
make-believe thriller the company is
urging them to keep their eyes open to
the very real risk never ever take off
your blindfold if you look you will die
do you understand in Bird box Sandra
Bullock is tormented by evil creatures
that turn anyone who sees them suicidal
she and our children wear blindfolds to
make their escape blindfolded copycats
have now popped up on social media oh my
god well many sons appear to have been
done for Laughs
others carry a little more risk this
woman nearly burns herself on a heater
this boy repeatedly crashes into
furniture with his tricycle and this
toddler slams into a wall on Wednesday
Netflix tweeted in all caps please do
not hurt yourselves with this bird box
challenge it also cautioned fans to not
end up in the hospital companies are
always a little concerned when something
takes off that's out of their control
Rebecca Keegan senior film editor at The
Hollywood Reporter also believes Netflix
sense is a marketing opportunity for the
movie the first time I heard about the
quote-unquote box challenge was by
Netflix warning people about the bird
box challenge
Bullock leads a cast of Hollywood
a-listers like John Malkovich Sarah
Paulson and trivanti Rhodes names that
normally light up theater marquees Jerry
I think it was gonna be anything like
this the company famously secretive
about its viewership figures boasted
more than 45 million accounts stream
bird box in its first seven days numbers
that can't be independently verified
I think Netflix really wants to
demonstrate to Hollywood that it takes
them seriously if they want to be able
to pound their chests just like you
would if you had a big box office
opening bird box was released in
theaters for only a week before Netflix
started streaming it although the movie
did well in test screenings prior to its
release Keegan says even Netflix has
been taken aback by the audience
response that 45 million number is
supposedly about a third of people who
have Netflix so I have not seen it yet
but can I just ask who blindfolds their
toddler I don't know parent of the year
yeah
and in videotape so too I mean yeah I
may pass on this one thank you